queen d5 g8 king h7 trick  yeah it was basically impossible because  as we as we said he was in a state of  shock yeah  yeah this is just over now because  quincy took queen of five and you run  out of checks and you have to allow  queen f6 check and you resign  yeah and then you can see on the body  language of magnus yeah he's very  pleased and yoga designs  wow  yeah very very very dramatic finish to  this game because george defended really  really well but as we were like after  after magnus played g2 g4 we kept on  saying that  you really should try to invest the time  in making sure that this is the last  calculation you do in the game and  he had the no he had a very very clean  force draw at that moment he chose not  to even  uh  look for it and uh  ended up it ended up costing him costing  him the game  yeah exactly because okay for example  this tell me at the end or also with 30  seconds on the clock